we are finally down to the last hours
fewer than 24 hours left in donald
trump's reign of terror depending on
when you listen to this and when you
watch today's show and
somehow as we really get ourselves ready
for a new administration a new
president a new start hopefully turning
uh uh
into experiencing an inflection point
when it comes to coronavirus and and
starting to go in a better direction
we still are seeing these last
gasps of desperation from donald trump
to see if maybe somehow he could do
something to open the window even
slightly to remaining in power
and now abandoned by so many
having conceded and i use that term very
narrowly
conceded that there will be a transition
that there will be a new administration
donald trump over the weekend had my
pillow
ceo mike lindell at the white house
who was spotted holding notes
where zoomed in uh photos showed
martial law and other of these
hair-brained
ideas and we're going to look at the
details and of course as rolling stone
and others have been reporting
we know trump is out of options we know
that we are mere hours
from donald trump leaving the office of
the presidency in
shame having lost the house for
republicans in 2018
having lost the senate for republicans
in 2020 and having made himself a
one-term president
and in so doing led to one of the
biggest global failures on coronavirus
the court challenges didn't work uh
pressuring republican politicians to try
to do weird things on january 6 didn't
work
focusing on the december 14th electoral
vote counts none of it worked
but trump had my
pillow uh guy mike lindell
at the white house seen entering on
friday
whose notes discussed martial law
and mike lindell although i'm not going
to play any of these agit
trash interviews that he's been doing
including from his private jet
insisting that there are still ways
there is still a path forward somehow
it appears as though as recently as 48
hours ago donald trump was still
exploring options
and still listening to people who had
these ideas
about martial law mike lindell's notes
also said insurrection act now
as a result of the assault something
something
martial law if necessary
so that is mike lindell's idea
for donald trump now importantly why is
a pillow manufacturer who believes trump
is a gift from god
uh advising a president of the united
states well the answer is in the
question
because he believes trump is a gift from
god
and these are exactly the types of
people that donald trump puts around him
he doesn't put an infectious disease
expert around him to manage a pandemic
he puts a neuroradiologist around him to
manage a pandemic
who happens to have a view favorable to
that of donald trump and
really i mean listen i don't know about
every country
but it seems that it is unique to the
united states
that a guy who sells pillows on late
night right wing media
would become a close advisor to a
president particularly
in that president's final desperate
shameful days in office
during a global cr a global crisis uh
the likes of which we haven't seen for a
hundred years the coronavirus pandemic
so
i received you know a ton of comments
about this story
about how terrible the my pillow pillows
are now i can't speak to that i've never
bought one of them i never would
but the important part is not about the
pillows
it's why is the pillow guy meeting with
the president of the united
states to offer advice and in particular
with a document that says martial law
written on it but it all tracks if you
call scott atlas to help you run
infectious disease why not call a pillow
guy
right if you want or believe jared
kushner is going to
solve the israeli-palestinian conflict
in four years
then it tracks that you would call a
pillow guy to advise you as to how to
try to stay in power despite having lost
an election so
it's all embarrassing it's all pathetic
there are already discussions of
you know is this beyond what should be
pardoned
by joe biden in the style of gerald ford
pardoning richard nixon
i'm going to address that over the next
day
i'll preview my position the answer is
absolutely not there is
no way under no circumstances
should joe biden even consider a
pre-emptive pardon of donald trump
now there's not a sign yet that joe
biden plans to do that
but there are more and more people some
on the right some on the left some
nonpartisan
who are saying for the unity of the
country joe biden should look at
pardoning donald trump because it'll put
an end to this stuff
no this stuff ends in 24 hours anyway
uh and i believe it would be a grave
mistake to pardon donald trump but i
will get to that i don't want to get
ahead of myself
before we get to joe biden being in a
position to pardon anybody
we have to get through tomorrow's
inauguration and i want to talk about
the horrible things going on there
one of our sponsors today is nerds for
humanity which is an
excellent youtube channel and podcast
that i would love for you to check out
nerds for humanity
is for people who love going really deep
into the nuances of politics and the
important issues
they cover a wide variety of topics from
elections to poverty climate change
corruption and much more and you'll find
long-form interviews with guests ranging
from
andrew yang and anthony scaramucci panel
debates and discussions with analysts
and content creators live streams where
tom the host of the channel
breaks down complicated topics and
interesting ways i'm a big fan
if you're looking to discover a
political commentary show
with a really unique and innovative
approach check out
nerds for humanity go search for the
podcast there's also a facebook page
and you can subscribe to the youtube
channel by going to davidpakman.com
nerds the link is right underneath this
video